we have learned the decision to host the
World Cup in Qatar has resulted in the
suffering and in the harm of countless
of our fellow workers a team United in
Collective activism as players we fully
support the rights of the lgbti plus
people but in Qatar people are not free
to love the person that they choose
addressing these issues is not easy and
we do not have all the answers
Australia's footballers are though
asking the questions other teams aren't
reflecting wider concerns with the World
Cup less than a month away
it's the most significant intervention
yet by players over qatar's treatment of
Migrant workers and discriminatory laws
LGBT fans are still put off from going
to Doha starting point is that World Cup
should not be in Qatar but is going on
and actually if we don't use this window
an opportunity you know the LGBT fans
like myself will be sat at home rather
than going out there to support the
three lines we can't can't partake in a
world cup that we'd normally want to be
celebrating and supporting our team with
because Qatar is clearly not suitable
um to be holding World Cup and something
as prestigious as a World Cup
Qatar says everyone is welcome
regardless of sexuality but same-sex
relations continue to be outlawed and
it's why even without FIFA approval yet
one love armbands will be on the England
and Wales captains irrespective it's
what we believe in and what we stand for
and we will be wearing the armband yeah
categorically categorically yeah
absolutely That's The Stance we make
yeah it's from the staff from the
association
we're not going to change our beliefs so
that's you know that's the right thing
to do
um and we firmly we we're strong in our
beliefs when Sky News visited Qatar this
month the World Cup leadership urged
players to stick to football people
should understand that this is a
festival this is a celebration of
football this is a this is a sporting
tournament that people want to come and
enjoy turning it into this platform of
of of of political movements and a
platform of political statements I don't
think is right for the sport and I don't
think this is the whole intention of
hosting the World Cup here in Qatar
whilst the reforms established in Qatar
are an important and welcome step their
implementation remains inconsistent and
requires Improvement today World Cup
organizers have commended the
Australians for using their platform to
raise awareness of important matters but
it's the transformative effects of the
tournament Qatar belief should be
recognized rather than the criticism it
sees an unprecedented and unjustified
the pressure that I was increasing from
players as the World Cup approaches Rob
Harris Sky News
and some of the other stories making the
headlines today and Scotland's Community
safety Minister Ash Regan has resigned
over gender recognition plans she said
her conscience wouldn't allow her to
vote with the Scottish government and
support the reform at stage one today if
accepted the bill will remove the
requirement for a medical diagnosis of
gender dysphoria when seeking a gender
recognition certificate
Prince Harry's Memoir titled spare will
come out on January the 10th with what's
been described as an account of raw
unflinching honesty the Publishing
Company also promises details of
Princess Diana's funeral from Harry's
perspective it was expected to be
released this Autumn but it's been
reported that the date has been pushed
back to allow changes to the publication
after the death of the queen to remove
potentially damaging materials
Buckingham Palace has declined to
comment on its contents
now the number of properties affordable
to people on housing benefits has fallen
by a third in the past five months Sky
News has exclusively seen figures
illustrating the rapidly growing gap
between benefits and Rising rental costs
our correspondent Adele Robinson reports
it's a sobering image a mother and her
two-year-old son homeless they group all
of us together people with mental health
and people who drink and do drugs and
stuff and then you've got us moms you
know and we don't really have a choice
we've got to be here this is temporary
accommodation they've been here months
I've got a thing at night time and stuff
if it's safe and you know I normally
lock my door with my buggy up against it
just as that extra protection Nicole
Works full-time but still needs housing
allowance that doesn't cover her rent
can I get on the back please each day is
a two-hour journey to her son's Child
Care a place she needs to live but can't
afford single